hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in lecture 31 the dissection of the
psychical personality
after having distinguished between three
agencies
within the psyche or the personality
namely the super ego the ego
and the ed sigmund freud is going to
bring up this
problematic of the ego
attempting to serve different masters
now a little bit before that
he talks about the ego as
having this tendency towards
synthesis right this is what
distinguishes the ego
from the id a combination and
unification in its mental
processes uh organization
um you know a certain kind of agency
allowing the ego to
select to to choose to prioritize
and this is precisely what
causes a lot of anguish
for the ego and here freud brings up
this
biblical proverb about serving two
masters at the same time and then he
says
the poor ego has things even worse
why it serves three severe masters
and does what it can to bring their
claims and demands into harmony
with one another so the ego is this
if we want to personify it's this poor
guy
who's got you know three screwed up
friends
all of whom want different things and
he's trying to make everybody
happy at the same time and it can't be
done it can be done
more or it can be done less but it's
always something that
when it happens it's a rather unstable
equilibrium that isn't going to stay
that way
and it requires retuning why won't it
happen well
because the claims made by these
three different masters are incompatible
and you know divergent they might come
together at certain points
you know when they're everything aligns
just just perfectly but
usually that's not going to be the case
and at this point we might say wait a
second what three masters are you
talking about
we've only got three agencies within the
personality freud's got superego ego and
id
super ego and id okay we can see how
they can be
not just distinct but also conflictual
or
antagonistic or you know demanding upon
the ego but what's the third master
well it's the external world it's the
outside it's other people it's
society it's the physicality of
objects it's the entire uh system that
we we live within
of space and time and the id
doesn't respect this at all the id isn't
actually connected with the ego
arises as we've seen out of the id
as a way of taking into account the
external world
and not allowing the id to get itself
killed
by willy-nilly pursuing the pleasure
principle
you know against all uh dangers
right so he says the these
claims are divergent often seem
compatible no wonder that the ego so
often
fails in its task its three tyrannical
masters
are the external world the super ego and
the
the id now in calling them tyrannical
what is what is freud getting at
you know none of them can be really
reasoned with
in their core they're always going to be
demanding or imposing and the best the
ego can do
is attain some kind of you know at the
time
modus operandi in in working with them
he also talks about them uh generating
anxiety and this is really quite
interesting instead of just talking
about anxiety in general
he tells us that each one of them
generates
its own particular mode of anxiety
he says if the ego is obliged to admit
its weakness it breaks out in anxiety
what kinds realistic anxiety regarding
the external world
moral anxiety regarding the
super ego and its demands and and its
you know judgments right
and also a neurotic anxiety
with respect to the id and the
instincts desires cajolings whatever it
is that the id is
is uh putting forth not being able to
attain what it is that that
that part of your personality wants and
so he talks about the
poor ego there's a nice turn of phrase
being
driven by the id right the it is telling
it give me this
i want this confined by the superego
that says don't do
that you dirty little pig you know and
and then attacks it and then repulsed by
reality and you might say why would
reality be repulsive well because so
much of reality has hard
edges and doesn't conform to
the thing that's driving us from the id
the pleasure principle
or even the demands of the the super ego
i mean reality
is what reality is and
it's not as malleable
and controllable as we'd like it to be
we could we should also mention here too
that a little bit earlier freud
uh told us that the super ego that we
are getting from within ourselves is
often also the product of the superego
of other people our you know authority
figures
so when we're talking about the external
world we are also talking about
dealing with other people's super egos
as well as their egos right so
how does this conflict play out
and here it's not as if there's just
like you know a triangle with
super ego id and external world here
it's rather that there's a dyad
of external world and ego that
the external world and id rather
that the ego is positioned between and
has to try to
reconcile there's also some relations
between the
ego and the id itself and then we've got
the superego over here
doing a different thing that
is connected with these other two poles
but isn't isn't exactly opposed in the
same way
so the ego mediates as freud says
between the id and the external reality
and he devotes some discussion to
how the ego arises out of the id
precisely to do this
so imagine like a four-year-old kid
right at
that age if any of you have ever had
kids or babysat them
you know that the main job that you have
is to keep them from killing themselves
or
maiming themselves or hurting somebody
else or doing all sorts of other
destructive and potentially you know
irrecoverable damage to
themselves and other things and that's
what the ego is doing the ego
is connected with the perceptual
apparatus
it's also connected with you know
understanding how causality
works within the the world so you learn
lessons like don't touch the hot plate
don't stick your finger in the mouse
trap you know all those those sorts of
things and you also learn about what's
pleasurable
and what you would want to pursue but
not to take too much of this particular
pleasure
you know i remember when i was a kid um
eating
two way too many red raspberries getting
sick on them and that and then not
wanting to eat them for about two years
i also did that with potato chips at a
party one time when i was a kid
as well uh so you know you learn these
these little lessons so the ego is
mediating between
all these desires that the id has to
just have a good time all the time
and one way freud frames this is the ego
brings in the reality principle to
oppose it to and modify the ids
pleasure principle the pleasure
principle is let's get as much fun as we
can let's have
as much enjoyment though that sort of
stuff is what i want to do
i want to avoid anything that's
irritating or boring
or you know harmful in the sense of
hurting me
right but the ego can say no no there
are things that are
hurting you that actually feel good and
there are also things that don't feel
good but they're very good for you so
like the ego is what can get you to the
gym
to keep exercising or to take the
medicine that you need to take
or to keep you at work working you know
beyond the two hours that work was fun
so that you can make a paycheck and
bring it home and
you know pay your insurance and put food
on the table and
pay your rent all those sorts of things
the ego
is the mediator between external reality
how whatever
the external reality looks like and the
id
and they're both making their own kinds
of demands
here he talks more about the kinds of
demands or commands that the id is
giving it tells
the ego what it wants and then the ego
goes about trying to find out if it's
possible to actually
attain those enjoyments or you know
avoid those distresses
and you know what the best ways would be
so you could say the
the id supplies some of the ends
but it's not conceiving them as ends is
just saying give me this
and then the ego is trying to figure out
okay i want to do that
how do i best attain it and it's also
dealing with the fact that the id
gives you all sorts of contradictory
demands it wants to get high
it wants to get laid it wants to lay in
the sun it wants to
you know do all these different things
all at the same time and the ego is like
whoa whoa
one one at a time which which one am i
supposed to satisfy because if i satisfy
this one you're not gonna get this one
right the ego
has this controlling
you know not a very strict sense right
uh sort of function and you know the the
ego
attempts as best as it can to satisfy
those that also
rationalizes as freud says some of the
things that the id desires you know so
the id can be quite perverse
might not fit in well with the rest of
one's society or
one's environment and the ego says okay
you can have that
but you can't do that that's that no
forget that right
and then the id doesn't like that so
there's all of that and then the ego
also can control like he says some of
the instincts not all of them but but at
least some of them and
it tries to make itself an object as
freud says for the the id
to attract what he calls the id's libido
to itself meaning the ego is trying to
get the id to
not just you know give it ideas about
what it wants to do but it wants to
siphon off some of that energy for the
ego's own purposes
as well some higher purposes so
that's one main issue and then we've got
the super ego the super ego
as freud says sets down standards
for the ego's conduct and it these
these standards are usually unrealistic
and
imperious and and generally can't be
completely
satisfied and part of why they can't be
satisfied
is because the super ego thinks that
it's the
only one who gets to to boss the ego
around
not taking into account that the id
and external world are also making their
demands
on this poor ego and the ego might
actually have some legitimate demands
or wishes or desires of its own the
super ego just keeps saying thou
shalt thou shalt not and it keeps
repeating these sorts of things
without taking it into to account
it's not a realistic faculty and then
when the
ego inevitably fails to do what the
superego wants it punishes it
with feelings of inferiority and guilt
in some cases it might actually you know
take the form of negative self-talk
you're no good
you dirty degenerate you know lazy
you know and there's kind of a whipping
and lashing going on
uh within the the person themselves so
the ego
is stuck between all of these
different things and actually at the
very end
of this this section freud tells us
something important about what
psychoanalysis
is supposed to be doing uh he tells us
that
the the intention of psychoanalysis is
to strengthen the ego
to make it more independent of the super
ego to widen its field of perception and
enlarge
its organization so it can appropriate
fresh portions
of the the id and and you know make more
of our life
subject to our own conscious
desires deliberation all of that it's
not to totally
you know make the ego the controller of
everything
it's just trying to strengthen it to
some degree against these
tyrannical masters that tend to produce
anxiety guilt and other negative affects
you